في الاثناء وافق اعضاء مجلس الدومه الروسي
على مشروع قانون تقدم به الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين الاسبوع الماضي يقضي بانهاء العمل
باتفاقيه القوات المسلحه التقليديه في
اوروبا الموقع بين الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق وعدد من دول الناتو عام
1990 وقال رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
بمجلس الدوما من الاتفاقيه ظلت منذ زمن
طويل حبرا على ورق وان الغائها يعزز امن
روسيا
ووقعت معاهده الاسلحه التقليديه باوروبا
في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس في نوفمبر عام
1990 من قبل الناتو وكان الحلف حينها 16
دوله وحلف وارسو الذي ضم حينها الاتحاد
السوفيتي وبولندا وبلغاريا ورومانيا
وتشيكوسلوفاكيا
ودخلت المعاهده حيز التنفيذ بعد التوقيع
بعامين استندت معاهده الاسلحه التقليديه
في اوروبا الى نظام القيود الكميه على 5
فئات رئيسيه من الاسلحه والمعدات
التقليديه للدول المشاركه فيها وهي دبابات
القتال والمركبات القتاليه المدرعه
والمدفعيه والمروحيات والطائرات المقاتله
وقد سمحت المعاهده للدول الاطراف بالتساوي
في عدد الاسلحه التقليديه والمعدات
العسكريه على ان لا يتجاوز عددها الاجمالي
40 الف دبابه قتال و60 الف مركبه قتاليه
مصفحه واربعين الف وحده مدفعيه من عيار
100 مليمتر ف ما فوق
و13,0600 طائره مقاتله واربعه الاف مروحيه
هجوميه
وحمل نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
بشان الغاء روسيا معاهده القوات المسلحه
التقليديه في اوروبا واعتبر ان الخطوه لن
تخلق احساسا بالامان لدى الدول الغربيه
موقف الغربي من خطوتنا بشان الغاء
الاتفاقيه لا يمكن ان يخلو من القلق كان
عليهم التشاور معنا قبل 15 عاما بعد ان
ابقينا ابواب الحوار مفتوحه منذ علقنا
العمل بالاتفاقيه عام 2007 المسؤولون على
الجانب الاخر يتجاهلون الاصغاء الى من
يهمه موضوع الامن الجماعي وضعهم الان لن
يتحسن بعد قرارنا الاخير